[Music]
hey everyone its Johanna here this video
is your request to lose the belly pooch
well there are three steps you will need
to incorporate first your food intake
plays a major part to get a flat belly
so be sure to eat a healthy and balanced
diet second is to do regular total body
workouts which incorporate both strength
training and cardio and do it for at
least three to four times weekly and the
third is to do workouts which train your
transverse abdominis which is also known
as your T apps this muscle is the
deepest of all your abdominal muscles
and it holds everything together so by
training on your T apps not only will
you gain a flatter tummy
you will also be preventing any lower
back pain by strengthening your spine
and your pelvis and that is what we'll
be doing today only five and a half
minutes long and I want you to do this
workout for at least two to three times
weekly there are a total of four rounds
we will start with one exercise in the
first row and we'll be adding one
additional exercise in each round only
30 seconds per workout it's going to be
fun and sore so here other workouts hip
twists full extensions elevator leg
lifts and flutter kicks we'll start with
the first run and the first exercise
which is hip twist so get into a plank
position and just drop your
if site-to-site ready let's go all right
so really tighten your ass
tighten your core and give me nice
proper forms okay
don't rush the workouts it's important
please keep your back straight and to
really tighten your core and feel your
transverse abdominis working all right
good job
keep going side to side very nice good
job
really tighten your abs keep your black
back flat nice now second roll back to
the same workout and we'll be adding
another workout which is full extensions
ready let's get back into Q twist fit so
we'll be adding more and more workouts
as the run increases keep going very
nice drop your hips side to side good
job doing well very nice keep going okay
keep your core tight keep your abs
strong nice can you view your cool
working get second workout break the
dumbbell if you want it you can choose
not to use a dumbbell then go all the
way
fully extend it crunch up to your ankles
punch it crunch and extend good remember
to only go as low as you can without
arching your lower back okay good job
touch your ankles
crunching very nice one more good rest
now round three we will be adding
another workout which is elevated lately
lips so let's start with hip twist
let's go good slides inside very nice
okay keep your back flat just drop your
hips very good and we're moving straight
into full extensions keep going doing a
good job and straight into full
extensions beginners you can do it
without any weights crunch extend
straight up good job so bring your legs
in and crunch it do your laps working
good all the way in all the way out very
nice
and next we're moving into the elevated
leg lifts good drop the weights and now
just bring your legs up and bring your
hips off the floor
slow and steady okay good there you go
don't rush it and to bring your hips off
the floor very nice
keep going good job
one more good rest
final round we will be adding flutter
kicks
so let's reset and get back into it
twist let's go
this is your final rock it side to side
very nice you're going with in and out
and straight into full extensions
good job guys all right full extension
grab your dumbbells punch in stand up
and go very good
remember to keep your back flat without
arching your lower back all right lift
your shoulders off the floor and crunch
up and straight into elevated Lake lips
go hips off the floor as much as you can
and really control it on the way down
good job good good shop really living
lives of the floor good keep going
nice few more and finally let's get
straight into static shakes all right
only 30 seconds not too high
really tighten your lower abs and just
let the small flutter kicks good job
come on guys hold it really feel and
engage Hilda laughs very nice keep going
small stop the cakes yeah Oh what
they're doing get it five more seconds
last one
and just rest and stretch it out so that
was a really quick though we'll have to
work out to lose the belly pooch you do
not need to do long abs workout but the
key is to do them regularly and to apply
all the three steps do this workout for
at least two to three times weekly and
you should see the difference in four
weeks all the best for new fitness food
and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter to stay
connected with me thanks guys
you
[Music]